*romantic music*
Doorman: Bonjour!
Host: Ahhh, bonjour!
Your table awaits!
Oh, hi!
I've got something for you
A rose!
*sniff* Ahhh!
Do you– Oh!
Thank you!
Bonjour!
Bonsoir!
You look so familiar.
Have we met?
Must be destiny!
OH!
*sniff* Ahhhh
Good year!
I can't wait to get to know you.
But it feels like I might've –
Oh!
*Deeply inhales*
*sigh*
It feels like I might've known you for a long time.
But either–
Ohhh my!
okay.
Either way, I can't wait to see what this date has in store.
*intense music plays while chef slams check book on table*
Chef: So who's gonna pay for this?
Mark: *nervously* Oh I can take care of....
...this... okay.
Alright.  Well, I...
*Chef's breathing intensifies*
...must have...
...lost it...
I- okay...
Maybe you could pay...?
...please?
Just once...